uh kind of hard okay let's play with
someone uh
whoa some guy with three thousand
traiting okay this is surely
my moment of glory so i retain some
rating
that's very very pleasant
and okay let's get back to winaver
finally time to shine with candidates
preparation
all right after the candidacy is over
well he actually knows the fine move
order
so kudos for him
what do i take on e5 right now
i guess he makes a castle and then what
somehow my my pieces become clumsy yeah
so if he makes a castle what do i do
i mean yeah i i supposed to know
something i'm supposed to but
as you can easily find out i don't
remember
anything okay let's just end the
development and
play on
sometimes it's just the the most you
know the most healthy way
of doing things okay now i can protect
the pawn
so in general i'm not too thrilled about
losing on f7 it just opens another file
and well i'll try to centralize
who is this player
no i don't want
it asked me if i want to quite the game
no i don't i want to stay
it's not g6 not sure if it's a good one
but
it looks quite reasonable
i think now i just protect on d4 first i
don't want to give this pawn
especially for free and then okay then
probably i'll try to take on e5
so if i take it what does he want to do
okay let's try
i mean okay he surely will out calculate
me
whatever i do so why not to
i need to help the guy
what's your most phone not just marry
all these candidates well
it's hard to say i think it was all
about chess
ah this is renowned lord suarez artist
soros yes
uh i guess uh luis suarez in football is
better than
ortiz suarez in chess but yeah he's
quite a strong player i guess
so the problem is like do i want to play
rook g3 right now or later so now i can
go for bishop d7
and then okay 94 g3 should always work
for me
okay so let's play bishop b7 first just
connect the rooks
and maybe f6 so like rook g3 is the
button i can always press
there is like uh hopefully no need to
rush
bishop e4 so i wanted to play f6 here
let's see if it works
okay it surely does but
so he just improves
well there is d3 move
i can also take what else
you can also try chase the queen
also there is like okay i don't kind of
like when you see okay there is knight
c3 but looking ic3 is maybe not the
not the worst thing which would happen
so let's get the pawn
queen retreats
it's important not to launch the remain
after bishop c6 but
hopefully uh i'll i'll do this
bishop 66 is very very annoying well he
takes another thing but
this is not so impressive
yeah bishop to six was the move i think
uh
i can go on e6 and just check the knight
now thank you again okay like plus
twenty plus twelve sorry